here's what would happen if all but one  woman disappeared from the face of the  earth  as the final woman on earth you would be  the only one who could speak up for your  gender which means your opinion could  easily get outvoted  there's a good chance this would make  you feel oppressed misunderstood and  more than a little angry  but that would be the least of your  worries if you were the last woman you'd  most likely be tasked with repopulating  the world  giving birth to a baby or two every year  would become your new life's work  scientists might also harvest eggs from  the only woman on earth and use  artificial wombs to repopulate the  planet every single birth would be an  international celebration especially if  the newborn is a female  as a society we'd have to make sure that  any repopulation effort would prioritize  the safety of all females born globally  so